BRADY HARAN: I want to share
with you some more one roll
Yahtzees, which have been sent
in by a number of our viewers.
And there's a few reasons
I want to share these.
Firstly, because
I said I would.
People have gone to a lot of
trouble making these videos,
and I really think we
should share them.
Secondly, it's a pretty
cool thing to see.
You'll remember from previous
videos, there's only a 1 in
1,296 chance of rolling one,
so when you get it, it's
pretty good.
And lastly, I think it's
fascinating to see how people
react when they finally
roll one.
MALE SPEAKER: Yes!
BRADY HARAN: So let's
go through some
more of your videos.
Some of them are quite funny.
Some of them, well, some of
them are a bit strange.
Here, Anthony rolls five 4's.
ANTHONY: There it is.
BRADY HARAN: A bit over par
there, but what an effort.
And how's this for a reaction
from Bill Vincent?
[GASP]
BILL: I did it!
FEMALE SPEAKER: Did you?
Did you actually?
BILL: Yes!
BRADY HARAN: Now, here's the
Benton family going for glory.
I'm not sure the kids were too
into it, to be honest perhaps
it was a chance to
stay up late.
If so, their luck was out,
because it only took 54 rolls.
Jacob here hit pretty much a par
score of 1,300 rolls, but
what a reaction.
JACOB: Oh!
Oh!
I did it
MALE SPEAKER: Oh my god!
JACOB: I didn't pay attention.
I was about to pick it up.
BRADY HARAN: James Foster
here hit the jackpot
with his 802nd roll.
And I know it took him 802
rolls, because he sent me
every single one of
them in real time.
Jesse Davis thought many hands
would make light work.
Clever thinking, but remarkably,
it took them a
combined 5,064 rolls until
this happened.
17-year-old Josh looks like he
broke out the fancy bowl for
this attempt.
Now, Lorenzo here did
it with software.
I don't think that's quite
getting into the spirit of
things, but clever anyway.
Here's Matthew.
MATTHEW: I did it.
I did it.
BRADY HARAN: Yes, yes you did.
And another Matthew, who really
put in the hard yards.
MATTEW: 1639.
And 1639, there it is.
BRADY HARAN: And now,
two Tylers.
1,471 rolls, and two handed
Tyler, who did
it in just 245 rolls.
TYLER: Yes!
BRADY HARAN: Now, Mike Tilly
here started with a plate.
He clearly got sick of the
noise, and there was a lot of
it, because here we go.
3,951 rolls until this.
MIKE: Yes!
I got it!
BRADY HARAN: Now, patient Pauli
was rewarded with my
favorite Yahtzee.
Five 6's.
And another all sixer, but this
one took just 143 rolls.
Hello, Rochelle.
RACHEL: Hi, Brady.
I'm sitting around at
home waiting for the
police to call me back.
I filed a report about some
credit card, my online report
didn't get accepted for some
reason, so I'm waiting for an
officer to call me back.
That always takes forever.
So I figured, while I'm waiting
around, I my as well
try to roll a Yahtzee.
BRADY HARAN: Rachel's effort
took so long she even changed
hairstyles.
RACHEL: 1,116 rolls.
It took me two days.
Here are my hash marks.
So let's recap.
After only 106 rolls, the
police called me back.
BRADY HARAN: Robson here gets
extra points for the
Numberphile branding.
And for over 3 hours
of effort.
Here's William Alves.
And I don't know how to
pronounce your name, uh,
Frumet, but you were definitely
one of our more
excited dice rollers.
FRUMET: I got it!
I got it!
I got five 3's!
I got a Yahtzee!
Oh my god!
BRADY HARAN: Now, Simon from
Germany, who's already
forgiven me for not being able
to pronounce his surname, did
the business in less
than two hours.
SIMON: Yeah.
BRADY HARAN: And here's Javier,
who rolled these
strange poker dice
2,559 times.
JAVIER: Yeah!
BRADY HARAN: Steven Christie
rolled these five 5's in 1,190
rolls, but he thought that last
die looked a bit dodgy,
so he had another go at
rolling a Yahtzee.
And the second time, it took
him about 400 rolls.
Stoe Farrell took an impressive
525 rolls
to roll five 5's.
STOE: Yes!
BRADY HARAN: And he tells me
he hit 4 of a kind 11 times
before the big moment.
JONATHON: Oh.
I did it.
BRADY HARAN: And finally, fellow
Australian Simon Brown,
and this reaction, well, it
sounds a bit familiar.
SIMON: That's it.
I've done it.
I've rolled a Yahtzee.
BRADY HARAN: I've done it.
I have rolled a Yahtzee.
That must be an Australian
thing.
Feel free to keep sending in
your 1 roll Yahtzee's.
I actually really enjoy watching
them, and you know
I'll make another video.